Guten Tag. Guten Abend. Mein Name ist Tessar Göftasch. Ich bin die zuständige Erstin für Sie, bevor wir anfangen, lassen Sie mich kurz Ihre persönlichen Warten notieren. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Peter von Norddeck.
Oh, Norddeck.
Dreinamen. Peter ist der Vorname.
Ja.
Und dann der Hauptname Norddeck.
Norddeck. Könnten Sie Ihr Nachname langsam bestreiten?
Ja. N, O, R, D, E,
C, K, Norddeck.
C, E, c, E,
Emil, C, R, K,
Norddeck. Peter sind Sie Herrscher?
Ja, sind Sie ein Mann?
Ja, okay. Herrsch Norddeck, wie alt sind Sie?
61 Jahre.
Okay, wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 26. Juni 1961.
Juni 1961.
Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,86 m groß und wiege 95 kg.
Okay.
Hi Norddeutsch, was tun Sie von der Ruf?
Ich bin Rechtsanwalt.
Rechtsanwalt, okay.
Wie ist Ihre Familienstadt?
Verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, zwei.
Okay.
Okay, hi Norddeutsch, was können Sie tun?
Ich heiße von Norddeutsch.
Schon gibt es von.
V-O-N, ein neues Wort, Norddeutsch.
Von Norddeutsch, ja, das ist Ihre Nachname.
Okay, ich habe klar verstanden von Norddeutsch.
Hi von Norddeutsch, was können Sie tun?
Beleichter, besprechen, hafen Sie im Moment.
Ja, ich habe seit zwei Stunden ganz starke Kopfschmerzen.
Beleichter.
Und ich kann auch ganz schlecht sprechen, das sprechen fällt mir auch schwer.
Sprächen Sie durchschnitts- oder wegen Ihrer Kopfschmerzen?
Meine Stimme ist so, geht so schwer.
Ich kann nicht richtig normal sprechen, ich flüssiger und schneller.
Okay.
Du warst schon ganz stark Kopfschmerzen.
Früher hatten Sie gleiche Dächer.
Du, was habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Okay.
Ja, zuerst, ich möchte einfach Dinge machen, zum Beispiel Ihre Oxigenz,
es wird z.B.
Ja, z.B.
Erweckung messen und es wird drückmesst.
Und EKG bündeln, danach mache ich eine Bargäte.
Okay.
Okay, jetzt habe ich etwas gemacht.
Ja, von Norddeck können wir weiter machen.
Wir haben gesagt, seit zwei Stunden ganz starke Kopfschmerzen haben und deutlich sprechen.
Gibt es andere Beschwerden, z.B. Kraftlosigkeit in Ihren Armen oder in den Weinen?
Nee, habe ich nicht. Mir ist sehr übel und ich habe auch dreimal erbrochen.
Okay.
Dreimal erbrochen.
Dreimal, dreimal.
Okay.
Und gibt es wundstige Schmerzen in Ihrem Köftest, außer Erkurschmerzen?
Ja, der Kopf, die Schmerzen habe ich im Kopf.
Ich kann auch nicht richtig sehen, ich sehe alles etwas verschlommen, unleutlich.
Okay.
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten beim Sehen?
Ja, ich kann nicht richtig genau scharf sehen, seit zwei Stunden.
Ja, ich denke, das ist ein Feier.
Aber etwas gemacht, aber ich bin nicht sicher, dass genug ist.
Ja.
Okay, aber wir haben ja schon etwas untersucht, Sauerstoff und Blutdruck.
Blutdruck.
Ja, okay.
Okay, ich habe noch etwas.
Okay, und gibt es sonstige Dinge, z.B. Taub, Haltgefühl, Grippen, in Beine, Arme?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Könnten Sie durch oder könnten Sie laufen einfach ohne Hilfe?
Ja, ich bin unsicher wegen dem Schwindel und der Übelkeit, deswegen laufe ich jetzt nicht so gerne.
Okay.
Okay, iPhone Nordic.
Okay, leisen Sie einen Königchen Erkrankungen?
Ich meine Blutdruckdruck, Zuckerkrankheit, Blutverzweifel?
Ja, ich habe hohen Blutdruck, so seit zehn Jahren, und dann nehme ich auch Medikamente ein.
Ja, wann war ich mit Medikamenten?
Moment, ich muss überlegen, ich habe meinen Zettel vergessen.
Bisoprolol nehme ich, morgens eine und abends eine, aber ich weiß jetzt die Stärke nicht,
kann ich mich nicht erinnern?
Okay, dann können wir noch mal.
Ich nehme noch Candesatane, ich messe ich die Stärke, 8 Milligramm, eine Tablette morgens und eine Tablette abends.
Okay, ansonsten nehmen Sie, ihr könnt auch Medikamente ein.
Sonst nehme ich noch einen Mittel für den Blutdruck ein, das heißt, schwierig, irgendwas mit Hydrochloro.
Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Ich weiß nicht genau.
Eine Tablette morgens.
Ja, okay, eine Tablette morgens.
Aber wie viel Milligramm, wie viel nicht?
Nein, meine Frau kommt hinterher, die bringt alle Sachen mit und auch den Medikamenten mit.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Sind Sie selbst ins Krankenhaus gegangen, gekommen oder vom Rekumst-Ians gebracht?
Ich bin mit dem Taxi gefahren.
Mit Taxi gefahren, okay.
Sonst gibt es eine andere Krankheit, Zuckerkrankheit, die Blutfette, ich hoffe, die Blutfette.
Nein, die Blutfette sind etwas erhöht, aber da habe ich bisher noch mich noch nicht dazu entschließen können, ein Medikament zu nehmen.
Okay, keine Medikamente nehmen Sie.
Ich habe keine Erdbeeren vertrage ich nicht und Kiwi früchte.
Sonst vertrage ich alles.
Kiwi, Erdbeeren.
Ich habe nichts gefragt, aber ich weiß, ich weiß, ich habe keine Erdbeeren vertrage ich nicht.
Okay.
Herr von Nordic, wo sind Sie jetzt?
Wo ich jetzt bin.
Ich glaube hier im Krankenhaus, in der Aufnahme.
Krankenhausaufnahme, ja, okay.
Welcher Tag ist heute?
Heute ist Mittwoch.
Mittwoch.
Okay, das ist gut.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, ich bin operiert worden an der Gallenblase vor zehn Jahren wegen Gallensteinen.
Vor zehn Jahren, Gallensteinen, okay.
Und als Kind, da war ich glaube ich acht Jahre alt, neun Jahre, ich weiß es nicht mehr genau, hatte ich eine Blindarm-Operation.
Sind Sie gegen Corona und gegen andere wichtige Krankheiten, wie die AB oder Kinderkrankheiten, wie die INS?
Ja, Corona-Impfungen habe ich drei geimpft und ich hatte auch im März eine Corona-Infektion.
Die ist aber gut verlaufen.
Okay, das ist sehr gut.
Okay, ich mache weiter.
Kann das damit zu tun haben, weil es heute ja so heiß ist.
Ich war heute etwas spazieren und in der Sonne, aber das habe ich bisher immer gut vertragen.
Können die Kopfschmerzen daherkommen von der Sonne?
Ja, natürlich, das kann sein.
Sie haben hohe Bedürfdruck, vielleicht kann das auch wegen hoher Bedürfdruck sein.
Und gibt es Probleme beim Augen?
Ich meine, leiten Sie an grauen oder grünen Stach?
Nicht grauen, aber grünen Stach.
Ich war das letzte Mal allerdings vor zwei Jahren beim Augenarzt, da war alles in Ordnung.
Ich sollte aber schon alle ein, zwei Jahre zur Kontrolle kommen, aber das muss ich jetzt auch noch mal machen.
Okay, ich raste.
In Ihrer Familie gibt es wichtige Erkrankungen.
Ich meine vielleicht Bedürfdruck, Superkrankheit, Bedürfdeckleite oder andere Probleme.
Mein Vater, mein Vater, der ist 87 Jahre alt, der leidet auch an hohen Blutdruck
und er hat auch eine Herz-Kranzgefäßerkrankung.
Und meine Mutter, die ist 85 Jahre alt, die hat eine chronische Chronikitis.
Haben Sie Geschwester oder gibt es Krankheiten bei einem Geschwester?
Ein Bruder, der ist 58 Jahre alt, der hat auch etwas erhöhten Blutdruck.
58 Jahre alt, erhöhen.
Okay, okay.
Gibt es andere Geschwester?
Nein.
Ihre Kinder sind gesund?
Kinder sind gesund, die leben aber nicht mehr bei uns zu Hause, die wohnen in anderen Städten.
Ja, das ist normal, ja.
Kinder müssen andere leben, erwegegen.
Okay, und haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, glaube ich nicht.
Gibt es Schwierigkeiten, ein oder durchzuschlafen?
Normalerweise nicht, aber jetzt mit diesen Kopfschmerzen glaube ich, könnte ich nicht schlafen.
Nicht schlafen, okay.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit? Leiden Sie an Appetitlosigkeit?
Mein Appetit ist gut, mein Arzt sagt immer, ich habe etwas zu viel Gewicht.
Ja, ein bisschen.
Ich will das abnehmen schon.
Ich will das abnehmen, in welcher Zeitraum?
Nein, das sagt mein Arzt, ich sollte abnehmen.
Ja, ich habe mich nicht abgenommen, ich nehme in der Sendenz hier etwas, immer etwas zu.
Sie wünschen, okay.
Und haben Sie Probleme mit dem Schulgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, ich habe voriges Jahr eine Darmspiegelung machen lassen, Vorsorge, Darmspiegelung, Gewinn, Ordnung.
Darmspiegelung, alles war gut, okay.
Okay, rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich rauche.
Seid man?
Eine Packung am Tag, das schon ziemlich lange, 40 Jahre.
40 Jahre, okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, nur an Alkohol trinke ich Fender, nur Bier, kein Schnaps, kein Wein, nur Bier.
Manchmal eine, manchmal auch zwei Flaschen am Tag.
Und das ist eine personische Frage, nehmen Sie nicht personisch,
eine ultimative Frage in die Frage, nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein.
Sie haben gesagt, TV gegen TV und Artbeeren, oder TV und Artbeeren,
Trinken Sie nicht, gibt es sonstige Allergie gegen etwas?
Nein, nur gegen Artbeeren und gegen TV.
Okay, halte ich noch mal, ich habe eine wichtige Frage,
eine wichtige Fragenwichtigkeit,
eine wichtige Situation,
die sonst etwas dazu hinzufügen, oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Also schon, was kann das denn sein, so etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt,
der Kopf ist ganz schnell, ganz heftig, also so stark habe ich das noch nie erlebt.
Ja, Sie haben vorwichtig, das ist eine wichtige Situation,
das kann eine wichtige Situation sein, aber es ist sehr früh etwas genau,
so sagen, weswegen Sie beschwerden, sollten Sie ein bisschen erst mal bei uns bleiben,
damit wir ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen können.
Dann können wir sofort noch mal sprechen bei Ihnen.
Okay, gut, können wir so machen.
Ja, okay.
Das ist eine Notfallidee, aber das ist eine Notfallidee.
Nein, nein, ist gut, ich habe das verstanden, das ist eine Notfallidee.
Ich habe viele Fragen.
Sind die Schmelzen abhängig davon, ob Sie stehen oder Kopfbewegung stehen?
Ich finde, es ist kein Unterschied, aber ich bewege ungern meinen Kopf.
Das mache ich gerne, das verstärkt den Schmerz.
Okay, bitte sagen oder zeigen Sie mir, wo die Schmelzen am Stechstein sind?
Ja, am stärksten sind sie so hier hinter Kopf, hier hinterm Ohr.
Und das ist so sehr, also ob jemand, also ob jemand etwas rausdrücken will aus dem Kopf.
Okay, danke schön.
Könnten Sie bitte die Schmelzen genarbe Scheibe und sind die Schmelzen eher dumpf drücken, pulsieren oder pochen?
Nein, die Schmelzen sind doch mehr dumpf, dumpf drückend und ganz stark.
Wie stark sind die Schmelzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10, wobei 1 sehr leicht und 10 sehr stark nicht mehr sind?
Oh, ich glaube 9.
Haben Sie das Bewusstsein verloren?
Das Bewusstsein habe ich nicht verloren, aber manchmal habe ich den Eindruck, weil mir so stark schwindelig ist und so übel ist.
Ich kann auch nicht so richtig sprechen, dass ich so kurz davor bin.
Okay. Haben Sie regelmäßig hier einen Blutdruck gemessen?
Ja, früher habe ich häufiger gemessen, aber in letzter Zeit war der Blutdruck eigentlich immer ganz gut.
Ich habe das letzte Mal vielleicht vor einer Woche gemessen.
Wie hoch war Ihr letzter Blutdruck?
Auch bei knapp 150, 150 auf 90, da müsste ich in meinem Apparat nachgucken.
Da wird das immer gespeichert, aber der Apparat ist zu Hause.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie 3 Mal erbrochen haben.
Wie sieht Ihr erbrochene Aus?
Ja, es waren noch etwas Speisereste vom Frühstück, aber kein ganz normales.
Da war jetzt nichts Blutiges oder so, so schleimig, gelblich.
Noch etwas gibt es bestimmte Auslösers?
Ja, auslöser für den Kopfschmerz.
Ich habe ja ein bisschen gedacht, vielleicht ist es heute die starke Sonne gewesen.
Normalerweise habe ich das bisher immer gut vertragen.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Haben wir noch so ein paar Minuten, dass Sie noch etwas schreiben und dann kommt der Oberarzt.
Meine Kollegen haben vier Fragen gestellt, aber Kessar hat diese Fragen gestellt.
Haben Sie nicht gewollt, was Sie lassen?
Das kann ich alles.
Sie können hier etwas sein.
Was?
Ich habe heute, glaube ich, bisher genug gepummen.
Aber Sie haben das Durst gefüllt.
Ja, bei der Wärme habe ich etwas Durst gefüllt, das stimmt schon.
Jetzt habe ich auch etwas Durst gefüllt, weil ich habe die letzte Stunde gar nicht getrunken,
aber ich wollte nicht trinken.
Danke schön.
Gut, bis gleich.
Ich habe auch etwas Durst gefüllt, aber ich habe noch etwas Durst gefüllt, das stimmt schon.
Ich habe noch etwas Durst gefüllt, aber ich habe noch etwas Durst gefüllt, das stimmt schon.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Ich würde gerne eine neue Hand, eine neue Hand, ein neues Handwerk.
Ja, Peter von Norddeck ist ein und 60-jähriger Patient, der sich wegen starken Kopfschmerzen,
ja, Kopfschmerzen bei uns vorgestärkt hat.
Seit wann hat er die Kopfschmerzen?
Seit vor 2 Stunden.
Er begicht jetzt fast, er hat schöne, nicht deutlich, der Sprache.
Er hat 3 Mal ein Wochen, Kraftlosigkeit, Haupthalt geblieben,
und er erwähnt, dass er nicht sehr gut sehen könne.
Hat er so einen Schmerz schon mal gehabt, oder ist das zuerst malig?
Erstmal, hat er gesagt.
Ich habe gefragt, und er hat erst mal gesagt, ja.
Haben Sie die Vitalparameter überprüft?
Ja, wir haben schon etwas überprüft.
Wir haben wieder zurück Sauerstoff-Sättigung und EKG.
Okay, gibt es beim Blutdruck Auffälligkeiten?
Nein, ich denke, aber keine Informationen habe ich hier.
Aber Sie haben den Blutdruck gemessen?
Ja, wir haben gemessen.
Also, wir gehen davon aus, der Blutdruck ist recht normal.
Hat der Patient Risikofaktoren?
Ja, natürlich.
Wenn ich das mal auf dem Sprache machen würde, dann würde ich sagen, ja.
Ja, natürlich gibt es ein paar Risikofaktoren.
Zum Beispiel, die Artigelische Patronie ist seit zehn Jahren bei dem Patient bekannt.
Und auch in Ihrer Familie, Bruder und Vater gibt es auch Artigelische Patronie bekannt.
Okay, cool.
Ja, er ist trauherrsch.
Ja, und?
Gibt es eine Verdachtsiagnose bei Ihnen?
Ja, natürlich.
Animes und Klinik durch den Armächtigens-Zerefrali-Impakt hin.
Ich habe das letztlich verstanden.
Okay.
Animes und Klinik durch den Armächtigens-Zerefrali-Impakt hin.
Schlag am Fall.
Okay.
Und das erklärt, dass diesen ganz starken Kopfschmerz, diesen schlagartigen Kopfschmerz ausreicht?
Ja, das kann sein.
Das ist ein Notfall-Zakt.
Was kommt differenzial diagnostisch in Betracht?
Differenzial diagnostisch, zum Beispiel, das kann auch Bilokon-Krise sein.
Ja, hypertonekrise, ja.
Aber wir haben den Blutdruck gemessen und der Blutdruck ist normal.
Ja, normal.
Aber ich meine, zum Beispiel seit zwei Jahren geht der Patient nicht beim Augenarzt.
Okay, also ein Blutdruck.
Ja, Bilokon-Notfall, das kann auch sein.
Oder ein Minigismus.
Hat der Patient einen Minigismus?
Ja, okay.
Hat er eine Nackenstaffigkeit oder hat er darüber berichtet?
Ja, eine hypertonekrise scheidet ja eigentlich aus, weil der Blutdruck ist ja weitgehend normal gemessen worden.
Ja, okay.
Eine wichtige Differenzialdiagnose haben Sie noch nicht genannt.
Das ist die Subarachnoidalblutung.
Und die Subarachnoidalblutung zeigt ja einen ganz plötzlichen Beginn mit einem heftigsten Kopfschmerz.
Beim Infarktapoplex gibt es sicherlich auch einen heftigen Kopfschmerz mitunter, aber links nicht so als Leitsymptom.
Ja, Bilokon-Notfall.
Okay.
Also da müssen wir sicherlich jetzt als erste diagnostische Maßnahme eine Bildgebung machen.
Des Schädels, ein TT oder MRTT geht wahrscheinlich schneller, um zu schauen, wie sieht die Gefäßsituation aus?
Gibt es Hirndruckzeichen eventuell auch?
Ja, nur ein Hirndruck, normalerweise entwickelt sich etwas langsamer als bei diesen Patienten, der den Schmerz ja ganz schnell bekam.
Also schlachartig war das ja ein Ereignis, ein Akuterreignis vor zwei Stunden.
Und wenn fürchte ich das vielleicht das Ehrrichtung einer Subarachnoidalblutung gehen kann?
Also CT-Untersuchung, Kreislaufüberwachung, um da jetzt akut auch eine Diagnostik zu machen.
Was im Anfang bei der Analyse vergessen haben, der Kollege hat das nachgefragt, war die Schmerzintensität,
weil ich immer wieder sage, ich habe so einen starken Schmerz.
Natürlich kommt differenzial diagnostisch aufgrund des heutigen heißen Wetters eventuell auch eine akute Hitze-Symptomatik in Betracht,
in Richtung eines Sonnenstiches oder eines Hitzschlages.
Der Hitzschlag zeigt manchmal ja auch solche Symptome, muss man differenzial diagnostisch abgrenzen.
Auch das sind natürlich Notfallsituationen.
Bei der Schilderung der Beschwerden versuchen Sie mehr medizinische Fachausdrücke einzusetzen.
Sie haben gesagt, der Patient hat Schwindel und hat Erbrechen.
Da hört der Oberarzt gerne die Fachausdrücke, Vertigo, Mausia, dass Sie daran denken, dass Sie das mit einbauen.
Sie hätten mir noch mehr erzählen können, aber ich als Oberarzt sehe eine Bedränglichkeit, dass der Patient jetzt schnell diagnostiziert wird.
Natürlich hätte sie sagen können, er hatte eine Gallenoperation, eine Cholätsystektomie und eine Abentektomie.
Diese Fachausbegriffe sind sinnvoll, dass sie die dann bei der Oberarztvorstellung zumindest nennen können.
Ich fand sehr gut, dass Sie gleich zu Anfang gesagt haben, das ist ein Notfall.
Normalerweise würden Sie jetzt anders vorgehen.
Die Gallparameter überprüfen, Blutdruckmessen, SBO2, EKW und dann die andere Anamnese später machen.
Ich denke, das war alles sehr gut, sodass Sie da sehr umsichtig schon gehandelt haben.
Oder vielleicht auch sagen, ich rufe jetzt, nachdem ich das so gemacht habe, vielleicht gleich den Oberarzt würde ich dann rufen.
Aber Sie sollen ja auch üben, die Anamnese zu erheben.
Ja genau.
Das haben Sie denke ich sehr gut gelöst.
Ja, danke schön.
Also nochmal dran denken, medizinische Fachausdrücke, es geht ja nicht darum, wer jetzt recht hat mit der Diagnose,
sondern dass sie versuchen eben die medizinischen Fachausdrücke von der Patientensprache in die Fachsprache rüberzubringen.
Und das wird glaube ich in diesen Prüfungen ja auch gewünscht.
Ja, genau, Sie haben recht.
Danke schön.